we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p call
anytime
take a listen to this voicemail hey
david this is Ken from California Wow
Alex Jones is just whacked out dude man
so this dude actually believes that our
federal that Sandy Hook was basically a
hoax staged by the federal government he
believes that the federal government is
and I don't believe this is putting
chemicals in the water to turn our
children gay and he goes on to say I
don't want them putting chemicals in the
water that turns the frogs gay what the
is wrong with this dude wow wow wow
thanks David bye I love this I'm so
desensitized to the insanity of Alex
Jones that when I hear something like
this it's so nice to hear from someone
who is actually reacting pat to the
shock of what alex jones says cuz i'm
completely desensitized to it yeah and i
mean at this point this guy has no
legitimacy at all to any of the claims
that he makes and if he was to make a
valid point whatsoever you could respond
with well you think that they're trying
to make the frogs gay yeah it's it's i
love the the wide-eyed naivete of ken
from california on the bonus show today
i've got some great stories from las
vegas i will give you an update on the
2017 david pakman show calendar I will
give you an update as to what's going on
with the David Pakman show
coffee beans and so much other stuff
david pakman.com slash membership coupon
code hey tree at 40 for a nice 40
percent discount off of membership